iphone 13 review music video with marcia
belski
take one
apple's come out with the
iphone 13.
now it's a new era of annoying food
photography
i decided to shoot a music video with
mostly iphone 13 models in the new
cinematic mode because well apple said
it looked amazing and that it's
hollywood in your pocket yeah except
this is not ready for hollywood the
cameras are huge so you can really
capture the deep
details
of your nasty at home
velveeta grilled cheese that no one
wants to see oh a new iphone every year
is that sustainable
the people are shaking in fear is it a
camera or a phone
that's a good question if you looked
around the studio that we shot this
music video in you'd think the new
iphone 13 models could sub in for
professional cameras
all these phones have brand new multiple
camera systems and along with them they
have a new cinematic mode
as you can see it's like portrait mode
for video it adds a bokeh or blur effect
to the stuff around your subject
you can lock the focus on one thing and
it will follow it or you can manually
tap on what you want to be in focus you
can do this during or after your shoot
that all works quite well it's a great
idea and a cool trick to make everyone a
film director that is if film directors
randomly shot things with blur all over
it
the feature really feels like it's in
beta and not quite ready for hollywood
what happened to her hair
or my fingers
in our studio here it struggled with
lighting conditions especially when i
used the telephoto lens on the iphone 13
pro
so we didn't see much blur and to be
fair the iphone did beat the samsung
galaxy s21 similar feature in this space
look at that blur on the paper but even
when we took the phone outside to shoot
more you can see what often happened it
struggled to calculate where one object
started or another ended unlike a real
camera this is using software to map out
the elements of the shot an apple
spokeswoman said cinematic mode is a
breakthrough innovation that will keep
getting better over time thankfully you
can go back after the fact and refocus
on certain objects and adjust the level
of blur you can even remove the entire
effect by tapping here
on top of those issues you can only
record in 1080p in this mode and while i
disabled hdr because it doesn't work
great when editing in adobe premiere
software our footage still ended up
recording in hdr
apple says that this will be addressed
in a software update
so yeah not quite a seven thousand
dollar sony fs7 professional camera
which shoots video that looks like this
the battery lasts longer on the pro
cause the dang thing is huge
it's really big
not sure that's how technology works but
i assume
so in the event of some apocalyptic
nightmare and you're stranded in all
alone
you have almost two full days to film
the zombies on your phone
i was most interested in testing the
cinematic mode for this video and it
clearly wasn't great but other than that
you'll be impressed with these new
phones especially if you're coming from
an iphone 11 or earlier
the designs and hardware look and feel
great and the iphone pro 13 models have
new pro motion displays that are much
smoother to scroll or swipe on battery
life was really the most impressive to
me even on this day where i recorded
video for hours and hours they all kept
up
a new iphone every year so here's what's
notable
multiple layers of nanometer scale
metallic ceramics apply it across the
surface for a stunning and very durable
finish
that just means there's a blue model
and the screens can track and they can
zoom and they can follow and they can
bloom
a budding film director's career
you'll just need lighting tech and crew
yet even with all that which i had here
your cinematic video probably won't look
better but your photos those will look
better all the cameras have new sensors
which take better shots in low light
conditions
my favorite trick the iphone 13 pro and
pro max let you take super close up
macro photos with the new ultra wide
lens
new iphone every year with incremental
changes larger displays and incredible
designs buy a new one every three to
four years
like me
[Music]
they'll get you with those updates
though yeah except maybe one of those
updates will make cinematic mode
everything i want it to be